new bombshell details in the case to
determine the origins of covet 19
a house gop report revealing the wuhan
lab
requested significant renovations to air
safety
and waste treatment systems in buildings
less than two years old major
renovations according to the house
committee such a significant renovation
so soon after the facility began
operating appears unusual
all raised questions about how well
these systems were functioning in the
months prior to the
outbreak of covet 19. fox news medical
contributor dr mark siegel joins us now
good morning dr siegel
morning ainslie good morning why a major
renovation
at the wuhan lab why are they asking for
these bids from companies
just two years after they open look
suspicious right
very suspicious now this comes from uh
rich edson our national correspondent
who i've been working with on the covet
origin story this is a big big break
because it's a big piece of this
why would a lab that's only two years
old suddenly have
issues with waste treatment and air
safety air safety with respiratory
viruses
in that lab and also he reported why
is the wuhan military games a ghost town
in other words there were no fans there
much as we have seen
here in september of 2019 ainsley
and people were reportedly getting sick
at those games and people came from
other countries
to those games and you know also when i
talked to robert redfield he said
that satellite photos in september of
showed increased traffic to hospitals
and medical facilities in the area
before long
we're going to end up calling this
covert 2018
and there's also evidence of issues of
not just lab leak because that's
becoming more and more and more
suspicious but
what was going on in the lab we're
trying to get to the bottom of this
could this could the viruses there have
combined genetics could they have been
run through
humanized mice research like that was
going on we always think of
science fiction was something done with
genetic editing but it may not have been
that
it could have simply been the way that
the virus was grown in the lab
and then leaked out of the lab all of
this bears further and further
investigation which
president biden has promised us but of
course it's right now
not across the aisle in terms of the
investigation
we were led to believe that the first
cases were seen in the wuhan area
november of 2019. you're saying now
september before that a few months
before
yeah and not only that i want to put a
spotlight on the idea that the initial
virus and and the lab by the way took
down
all of its viruses all of its sequencing
took it down off the web
right around the time the suspicious
stuff was happening but also
it turns out that the structure of the
virus doesn't fit with a wet market
whatsoever that's been recently found at
the bloom lab here in the united states
in other words it clearly came from
before november 2019
clearly months before and doesn't fit
the wet market at all
you know i'm sure all of your friends
and especially in your profession and
all of your patients are asking you are
we going to shut down again
they're worried about this delta variant
if you look at australia
they have police helicopters flying over
the beaches
and telling people to get off the beach
watch this
[Music]
they're forcibly locking people down are
we going to see something like that here
do you think dr siegel
i certainly hope not first of all it
doesn't work
lockdowns were used extensively in
australia throughout the pandemic as you
know and kept the numbers down
twenty thousand cases uh in victoria
nine thousand cases in new south wales
now they're starting to see an increase
in cases
475 yesterday and they're panicking with
a police state
listen ainsley here's the science of
this australia locked down the whole
continent okay and they didn't let
anybody in and they kept the numbers
really low now according to my sources
doctors practicing there
they're having trouble getting people to
take the vaccine because they think
it's a theoretical threat but the virus
is of course
a real threat so then they're responding
the government is by more and more
superimposed police state lockdowns but
when the virus
and we learned this here the hard way
when the virus is already going through
households you can lock down all you
want
it is not going to prevent spread and
that's what they're learning in
australia all they're doing is causing
great collateral damage
psychological harm and trauma and people
separated that's just
the wrong way to go dr siegel thank you
for coming on with us today
always my pleasure ainsley always thank
you